on ne s'attend pas en principe à trouver
autant de tracteurs et d'exposants dans
un festival de non labour est pourtant
là fini les sols propre et sans vers de
terre des sols cave et d'intrants
l'agriculture vit une révolution
démonstration nous sommes face à un
appareil qui travaillent le sol dans un
premier temps et qui place les semences
en un seul passage l'avantagé de réduire
donc le nombre de passes et donc
économiser du temps du carburant de
l'argent avec l'apparition de la
révolution industrielle et des produits
phytosanitaires on a détourné
l'agriculture de son but premier c'est à
dire de travailler avec le sol avec
l'apparition de ce type de matériel ont
réduit le nombre de passages on cherche
à travailler à de plus en plus avec le
sol donc à faire revenir la vie
microbienne et c'est de manière à ce que
les sols soient de plus en plus fertiles
et que les rendements soient naturels
dont les allées de ce festival beaucoup
de visages jeunes l'agriculture au
féminin a déjà ses représentantes
mes parents sont sur une exploitation
d'environ 300 hectares
une sont en polyculture élevage ils font
de la vigne des vaches et les céréales
et par la suite on voudrait que la
grandir et à reprendre la ferme de mes
parents avec mes frères tu as décidé oui
tu y crois oui
lancé il ya vingt ans avec l'appui de la
coordination rurale
le festival national de new labour et
semis direct est un défricheur d'idées
les gens qui confond fait aulas 25 30 40
ans qui font les semis direct les autres
qu'on commençait qui se tâtent le qui
soit encore le bout parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de ça il ya beaucoup de choses
à comprendre du sol et il ya les gens
qui s'ils sont incertains et qui
viennent s'informer pour voir s'ils
pourraient y faire chez eux c'est nous
sommes à une journée d' échange une
agriculture de conservation des sols
avec très peu d'intrants c'est le
message à retenir de ce festival